ça la ville de s'adapter aux besoins des
touristes donc ondes et déposerait
plutôt en haut de la ville et par
exemple on pourrait leur permettre
d'aller aux toilettes avant 10 heures le
matin ce qui n'est pas le cas face à
auxerre
or j'ai tout simplement dire à
christophe berhault que s'il date que ça
comme propositions pour redonner de
l'attractivité la ville
ça va il n'y a pas de souci à se faire
de projets en fait c'est d'aller vers la
gratuité des bus urbains
parce que les la cinquantaine de villes
en france qu'il a mis lyon perverse
perçoit que c'est une réussite en fait
par contre sur la question effectivement
des transports en commun moi
personnellement je ne suis pas favorable
au tout gratuit
c'est une fausse bonne idée il ya
beaucoup de spécialistes aujourd'hui de
l'urbanisme et des transports qui
explique que le bus gratuit entièrement
gratuit en fait sa concurrence ça ne
permet pas de limiter la circulation
automobile en ville
sa concurrence directement qui sa
concurrence les piétons et sa
concurrence les vélos à liszt les
printemps pour auxerre que je mène
c'est une gratuite est modéré c'est à
dire que ti d'abord lutté pour les plus
jeunes pour les moins de 18 ans la
gratuité
elle est particulièrement adaptée aux
villes moyennes aujourd'hui les anisés
vont là dessus c'est ça bouge beaucoup
dans ce domaine vous avez répondu alors
jobin pas d'accord avec vos d'havard
jalousie sans doute d'autres d'ailleurs
y est la gratuité ça n'existe pas il y a
toujours quelqu'un qui paye je crois qu
on a trois candidats qui globalement
veulent extraire la voiture du
centre-ville
là dessus on est d'accord et on a un
candidat qui pensent que l'avenir du
centre-ville passe encore par un parking
hypercentre c'est un projet qui à 40 ans
jean pierre soisson parlait déjà d'un
parking hypercentre à auxerre nouvelle
génération issue des quartiers qui a
plutôt bien réussi qui est parfaitement
intégrée à souhaiter que je puisse mener
une liste afin de porter des idées puis
parce qu'il y avait un intérêt de
de l'action publique mettre la lumière
sur les quartiers populaires qui ont été
délaissés depuis une vingtaine d'années
une personne tout seul à décider de
refuser les cris fication sans même
consulter les habitants concernés par
cette desserte ferroviaire
je suis effrayé je suis effrayé par la
méconnaissance des dossiers par monsieur
bah ça fait quatre semaines l'opinion
publique que la communauté
d'agglomération à laquelle il a
appartenu
j'en ai bavé un vice président il a fini
par quitter la communauté
d'agglomération il est élu local il
devrait suivre les deux soyons ensemble
capable de vente ce qui faut les est où
la force de ce territoire plutôt que de
pleurer comme ça c'est une préfecture
n'était pas le premier bassin d'emploi
d'un département franchement là et de
confondre de dire que c'est une critique
alors que justement on est plutôt dans
un constat factuel c'est à dire il faut
accepter la vérité pour essayer de
trouver les bonnes solutions
j'écoutais attentivement chris barraud
visiblement il ne maîtrise pas le
dossier tout à fait être clair ce que
vantent depuis lors à son frère dans le
nord mais il ya eu des bribes de
transition que mais peut-être qu'il faut
aller plus loin maintenant aujourd'hui
c'est pour ça qu'on a fait une liste à
part en fait différemment
d'abord avant d'avoir en matière de
tourisme qui est un élément essentiel
d'attractivité de la ville et de
vitalité du commerce
jbe remplace avec toi avec 2/10 et avec
d'autres une stratégie de vup autorise
ce qui porte ses fruits aujourd'hui donc
là dessus il ya vraiment pas de une
feuille de papier à cigarette entre
d'eau denis je t'écoute tous les sujets
que tu évoques là ils sont déjà engagés
et j'ai envie de te dire une chose tu
l'as pas le boulot paul de l'écologie un
phare et pas à d'autres
et tu es contact avec moi tu es
comptable avec moi duby lobbies